Das sind böse Kommentare, die die Philosophie beschädigen, die
sie für den Staat tanken
- gähnt Bama, dunkles Gewebe, statt
Standort ONC, zu weit, sogar Parma, Mann,
vielleicht mr.  hundin condo stehlbar
al-anon con yoga in feelin felon and
Viet cloud aluminium
hochtechnisch stählerne bazooka a ferreted NJ HP Cruces Ich
hatte hier in Berlin diese
winzige devikanto-schablone zum einloggen
und außen professor eine andere
hyperasiatische universität von yahoo  feierlich auf
ihrem RSS in der Polizei bestanden, aber Websites, die
auf diejenigen stehen, die Hilfe leisten, um mir zu helfen,
ja zu sagen, wenn Ihre gemeinsame Chloe verliert, sehen Sie, wie
das schlecht ist
wird nicht enden, aber immer mehr
Liebe endet sie ist zu einem festen
Bestandteil unseres Lebens geworden und so stellt sich die Frage,
warum einer der Gründe dafür
ist, dass Menschen im Gegensatz zu früher
ihre Sexualität
immer mehr erforschen und weil Sexualität
glücklicherweise legitimer geworden ist, dann können
sie jetzt Partner akkumulieren und bei der
Akkumulation von Partnern haben sie fast
zwangsläufig mehrere Beziehungen,
bis sie, sagen wir, eine haben  große Liebe
oder bis sie sie nicht mehr haben und bis
du weißt, dass sie eine Reihe von sich
anhäufenden Beziehungen haben, also wenn wir
über das Ende
der Liebe sprechen, meine ich damit nicht, dass
jede Liebe zum Ende verurteilt ist,
meine ich  Nur dass die Struktur unseres
Lebens so ist, dass wir uns fließend
von einer Geschichte zu einer anderen bewegen, wissen Sie,
dass de lis basierende Angelegenheit,
die für einen kopflosen Assistenten einen
freiwilligen Naturschutz hinterlässt, wie es wurde, wenn
Sie keinen hi Mohammed VI Ganesha /
D-Lehrplan für sie erhofften  Nichte Sofia und
sind unendlich Studentenausbildungen McLeish
Führung II versuchen Konzession nach sagt
Angst tut Akuma Schemata Lava tut
Abteilung Azam bekam nicht Tosh rebake ähnliche
Schuld quasi die Mutter heiß neu in einer
Investition Batum Sexualität italienische
Kanone der unflätige Investitionspartner,
den Wirtschaftswissenschaftler über  weil er
dicht designt wie ich denke man kann die
fähigkeiten menschlicher gewebearbeit behalten und
uns in der gärung wieder in die frachten
lassen ist das natürlich unglücklich
i  Dass der Fortschritt aber ein Fortschritt bedeutet nicht
, dass die Dinge einfach sind oder
dass sie notwendigerweise glücklicher waren, so dass in
früheren, sagen wir, traditionellen Gesellschaften
Scheidungen viel schwieriger waren und die
Wahl nicht einmal wirklich möglich war,
hauptsächlich für Frauen, aber sowohl für Männer als auch für
Frauen  Die Fähigkeit, seinen Partner zu wählen,
wurde begleitet von der
Fähigkeit, seinen Partner auf eine
Weise abzuwählen, die darin besteht, sich aus einer
Beziehung zurückzuziehen, wenn Sie dies wünschen. Der Preis
für eine größere Auswahl besteht also darin,
dass wir das Objekt der
Uncho von jemand anderem sind  oder dass wir selbst die
Wahl eines anderen ausüben, so dass dies
ein Fortschritt ist, wenn Sie an die Idee der
Autonomie und Freiheit des Einzelnen
glauben und wenn Sie an die relative
Autonomie des individuellen Visums gegenüber dem
Gemeinschaftsvisum gegenüber der Religion und sichtbar der
Gesellschaft glauben  aber Fortschritt bedeutet nicht, dass die
Dinge wie gesagt einfacher sind oder dass sie
uns Glück bringen. Wir können Fortschritte machen
und weniger glücklich sein. Hmm.
Ich denke, das ist es, was wir
rückgängig machen müssen  rstand auf dem höchsten der verleumdung
alles stimmt mich, da ich speziell manische
lieder logik klick lachemann
ja, genau das habe ich gesagt, und ich
denke, oft verwechseln die menschen die beiden
und dies ist die weise oder der grund, warum
konservative leute die
zeitgenössische oder liberale gesellschaft kritisieren  Normen oder
nicht Freiheit, weil sie beobachten,
dass diese größere Freiheit
nicht zu größerem Glück führt, und
ich denke, wir müssen eine Wahl treffen, und wir
haben sie kollektiv getroffen, nämlich ob wir es
vorziehen, glücklicher oder freier zu sein, denke ich
wir wollen gemeinsam lieber glücklich sein
wir wollen lieber frei sein freier
auch wenn es weniger bringt Ich glaube ich meine ich
würde nicht Glück sagen aber weniger
Wohlbefinden Ich glaube nicht dass wir
als Individuen gut gerüstet sind um davon zu leben  unsere
eigenen, um außerhalb starker Gemeinschaften zu leben,
aber ich denke, Gemeinschaften haben sich nicht bewährt.
Ich denke, die meiste Zeit
haben Gemeinschaften Frauen unterdrückt,
Gemeinschaften mögen keine Fremden, die sie nicht mögen,
also ist der Preis dafür zu zahlen
aus meiner meinung nach ist für freiheit mehr
moral, das heißt mehr gleichberechtigung zwischen
männern und frauen und mehr gleichberechtigung zwischen
mitgliedern einer gemeinschaft und fremden
der gemeinschaft, als mir dies passierte,
nachdem ich lucretia mott kennengelernt hatte und
wir dampf von kadesh of 2d installierten,
erschraken  Kind die Heimat für mich Austin
ist die Geister in unserem Irrationalen Du
weißt, ich weiß nicht, wie du
Rationalität definierst Rationalität vom
Standpunkt des Individuums aus ist
definitiv lieber
autonomer zu sein Ich meine, wenn du, wenn du
zum Beispiel wählen kannst, wie  Beherrsche deinen
Körper denke an Frauen Die meisten Frauen denke ich,
wenn du sie fragst, ob sie
das Wetter wären, würden sie wollen, dass
ihr Körper unter der Obhut von
Männern steht, wie es bis in die 1960er und 70er Jahre der Fall war,
oder ob sie
die Strömung bevorzugen würden  Situation, in der sie
volle Autonomie und Eigentum über ihren
Körper haben und sich dennoch in einer Situation befinden, in der
sie sich
ihrer Ehekarriere, ihrer Mutterschaft
usw. anscheinend weniger sicher sind  Ich denke, dass die meisten Frauen sich dafür
entscheiden würden, autonomer zu sein und die
volle Kontrolle über ihren Körper zu haben. Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir uns überhaupt vorstellen könnten,
in die Situation vor den 1960er Jahren zurückzukehren, in der
Frauen die Zustimmung ihres Mannes brauchten,
bevor sie ein Geschäft eröffnen konnten  Bankkonto, also
denke ich, dass wir gemeinsam
nicht mehr zurückgehen können, also denke ich, dass sich diese Frage von
selbst beantwortet. Es ist vollkommen rational
in dem Sinne, dass wir
uns nicht entscheiden würden, wir würden nichts anderes wählen als das, was
wir heute haben, wenn Sie
es weglassen können  ist ein trend keine
manipulation v10 wenn oft beginnt und
gewinnt atlanta-basiert ist der trend mit meinem
sinn, unsere haut mr zu werfen.  su Männer
und naja das sind ein paar
Erkenntnisse aus den 1980er und 90er Jahren ich
weiß übrigens nicht ob es noch
aktuell ist Ich denke auch immer mehr
Männer entscheiden sich mehr als früher für das Leben von Beziehungen
Aber traditionell war
der Grund, warum mehr Frauen
Trennungen einleiteten, erstens, weil Frauen
in den Arbeitsmarkt eingetreten waren und Frauen daher leichter aus der Ehe ausstiegen, wenn
sie wirtschaftliche Alternativen und
Möglichkeiten hatten,
und zweitens Frauen und Männer
eine unterschiedliche emotionale Sozialisation durchmachten,
Frauen wurden sozialisiert,
um sich um andere zu kümmern  ihre
Gefühle auszudrücken und deshalb
dasselbe von Männern zu erwarten Männer
hingegen sind auf dem kapitalistischen Markt dazu
sozialisiert, sehr wettbewerbsfähig zu sein
und keine emotionalen Ausdrucksformen zu zeigen, und
daher ist es für Männer viel
schwieriger, auf die Anforderungen von Frauen einzugehen,
die  sind anders sozialisiert, also denke ich,
dass die Frauen aus diesem Grund
diejenigen sind, die eher
emotional frustriert und drei
ungleich sind  Im Haushalt besteht immer noch eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit,
und die Person, bei der das Geschlecht am
ehesten eine Doppelschicht zu Hause macht, sind
die Frauen, die sie draußen arbeitet, und sie
arbeitet zu Hause, wobei die Männer ihren Anteil nicht abziehen,
und daher sind Frauen
eher unzufrieden, wenn sie einige sehen
Künstlerin Anish ist mir bisher ein
brüderliches Geschenk de ma vie de ferran
Archetyp isch von Tokens in Anand Reis oder
einer Maschine und zu schmerzhaft für nicht einmal
das Training, das sie oft ausleihen -
auf Körperhaltung Alma Ermüdungsanekdote Smith
in unserer Analyse in Croissant  in der OVA
im Weltraum und schon oft Peron
ctt eine Autobiographie von Bertrand
Russell Zimmerman Phyllis oft sie
ankamen kam Jenny schwer zu angehäuft
und nach dem Mittagessen war es ein Hinweis auf den
hartgesottenen Adam, der
die Demokraten spaltet, da jeder Dummkopf
nicht gehen kann  Und Tyramine als Tat, die
er verklagt werden musste, ist Amalgam. Preakness erkennt, dass
die nicht gruppierten Minen ein bisschen so sind, dass
Ian Oculus nicht zum Foul und Fls
wusste, wie der Tank  Mondo Hagen,
also ist Shrek, du weißt, das ist ähm,
das ist nicht unbedingt, was passiert ist,
es ist nicht die Wahrheit dessen, was passiert ist, es
ist, wie er sich die Geschichte erzählt, wie
er aufgehört hat, sie zu lieben, also könnte es tatsächlich sein,
dass sie auf ihrem Weg war  hatte
ihn auf sehr viele unsichtbare Weisen enttäuscht,
die er sich selbst nicht
eingestehen wollte, und dann und dann,
irgendwann kommt ihm diese Sache ins
Bewusstsein und er beschließt, sich selbst zu sagen
, dass er sie sowieso nicht mehr liebt,
aber das ist
mein Punkt  Sagen Sie, dass Nichtlieben nicht nur
der Prozess der Loslösung von
einer liebevollen Beziehung ist, es nimmt viele
Formen an, sondern es braucht auch viele Erzählungen,
also gibt es sowohl unterschiedliche Prozesse
als auch unterschiedliche Geschichten
, die sich die Menschen
erzählen  oft fragt Bombe nicht ein paar Lots
oder eine Sekunde, klopft auf den Kopf, es
füllt mich mit Scheuern aus dem Noggin,
ja, das wäre die Epiphanie, mit anderen
Worten, es ist ein fallendes i  Liebe in
umgekehrter Richtung, so wie sich manche Menschen
einfach auf den ersten Blick verlieben, indem sie
eine Person ansehen und sie wissen, dass sie
für diese Person bestimmt sind, also würde ich diese
Erzählung der lieblosen Erzählung des
Verliebens in umgekehrter Richtung nennen, wo man
plötzlich versteht  dass du aufgehört hast
, diese person zu lieben, es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten zu erklären, warum du aufgehört hast zu
lieben, du kannst dir gut sagen, dass
sich so viele enttäuschungen und
so viele frustrationen angesammelt haben, dass
es irgendwann einfach zu viel wurde und überlief
es ist das bild des wassers
, das überläuft  der Krug, und es gibt auch eine
andere Erzählung, die ich gefunden habe, nämlich
die Erzählung über ein Trauma, in der Ihr
Partner etwas tut, das Sie
richtig schockierend finden, und Sie sich nie
ganz davon erholen, nie ganz
vergeben und nie wieder voll vertrauen,
und das rufe ich an  eine Erzählung über ein Trauma,
weil es so ist, als wäre es ein Bruch in der
Vertrauensbeziehung, die zwei
Menschen miteinander haben, und dann, wenn die
Trennung  Ration kommt, Sie bezeichnen diese
Ereignisse als die Ereignisse, die ankündigen
und bereits sagen, was sein wird,
aber auch dies sind mit entsprechenden Berichten,
wir wissen nicht genau, ob dies
tatsächlich die Gründe sind, aber dies sind
rückblickende Berichte, so dass CCM Island
ähnliche sogar bestellt hat  Eine Schwimmsocke in
99 englischer Liga und eine erdrosselte hebräische
Schande, die für einige vo Smetana-Insel-
Ashish-Team in Ständen alle Schweißausfälle und
damit seine Gefühle in der Ochsenmarke
bestrafte, um in Spielbänden auf Selva zu schlafen,
sogar unser Erster
zu sein  Indisches Krankenhaus ja, das ist es,
was wir tun, aber das Buch in meinem Buch eines
Heimwerkers beendete das, was ich versucht hatte
, zu sagen, dass wir
einerseits diese rückblickenden Berichte haben,
andererseits aber objektiv sind
Kräfte, die Menschen mehr
als zuvor trennen, also geht es nicht
nur darum zu verstehen, welche Art von
Geschichten wir uns erzählen, sondern auch
darum, zu verstehen, warum die Gesellschaft,
in der wir leben, so ist
Kräfte erschafft, die stärker sind
als unser Wunsch zu lieben und geliebt zu werden, und
die das
für uns unsichtbare Band, das die
Beziehungen, die wir zu schaffen versuchen, untergraben hat, von innen heraus untergräbt. Moderne
Gesellschaften enthalten sehr viele unsichtbare
Kräfte, die es den Menschen sehr schwer machen
, zusammen zu bleiben  was ich
in diesem Buch zu dokumentieren versuche okay jetzt
intim Indien Englisch Pam Trauer sein die
Negativität auf der Schwester Ich kann
Trauer sein zu erschrecken uns zu verstehen Ende in
Croissant hua ist unter auf dem Signal Tag
und Gerechtigkeitsproblem das Negative in beschäftigt
auf a  Ganesh Connie so gibt es die
Schwester Anna
treinen Comte Sohn Ehrlichkeit negativ 18i
Ganesh Kearney reichhaltiges Gericht beginnt innerhalb
garnieren mich wirklich falsch Song Ji Hoon so
Fernanda und so lockern Sie den Status halten Sie
rede kokonierte Zisterne sind so treinen Palast pikant
Conny Contino mr.  Klein war der Himmel
jetzt für jede Negativität,
also hat das Wort negativ eine lange Geschichte
in der Philosophie. Ich werde diese Geschichte nicht weiter ausführen,
aber lassen Sie mich einfach sagen, dass ich
zwei Bedeutungen aus den phänomenologischen
Traditionen verwende
des Bewusstseins
als unbestimmt bedeutet, dass wir in gewisser
Weise keine Attribute haben, das
Selbst hat für
Sartre keine Attribute zu kaufen, und deshalb ist es frei und
unbestimmt,
dass wir nicht wirklich wissen, was wir wollen,
weil wir  nicht wirklich wissen, was wir sind,
und das ist der Zustand der Freiheit,
es ist ein Zustand, der sowohl sehr gut ist
als auch Angst erzeugt, und die zweite
Tradition, aus der er stammt, die
ebenfalls aus der Phänomenologie stammt, aber etwas
anders als Heidegger ist, ist für
mich negativ  was passiert, wenn das, was du
normalerweise tust, zusammenbricht, und wenn
etwas zusammenbricht, musst du
plötzlich darauf achten,
was du tust, selbst wenn es noch eine Sekunde her war
als völlige Routine und du hast
nicht daran gedacht, aber für
Heidegger ist das, wenn du eine kreative
Bewegung willst, es ist ein Ausbruch, es ist ein
Moment, in dem die Dinge zusammenbrechen und sie
uns zwingen, die Welt zwingt uns, darauf zu
achten, das ist es, was auch ich  Mit
negativ meinen wir dieses Zusammenbrechen und
Beziehungen, von denen wir wissen, dass sie
jederzeit zusammenbrechen können, ob wir in ihnen sind oder
bevor wir sie betreten, und
deshalb zwingen sie uns, ihnen Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken,
das ist es, was Psychologie in gewisser Weise
meine ich klinische Psychologie  und es zwingt
uns, auf die lauernde und ständige Gefahr zu achten,
dass Beziehungen unsere
bereits zerbrochenen Beziehungen zerbrechen und die wir
zu verstehen versuchen, weil sie
zerbrochen sind, also sind dies die beiden
Bedeutungen von negativ, die ich in dem Buch verwende,
und als  Sie haben zu Recht angedeutet, dass eine der
Hauptthesen des Buches darin besteht, dass
dieselben Kräfte, die es sehr schwierig
machen, Beziehungen einzugehen, dieselben
Kräfte sind, die wirken  Wenn
Menschen langjährige Beziehungen haben und
diese Beziehungen auseinanderbrechen und
zerbröckeln, ist genau das der Einsatz des
Buches. Es soll zeigen, dass es die
gleichen Kräfte sind, die in beiden
Fällen wirken
.  Samito Thunfisch Pasta Beat sogar aufgeschlitzt,
wo weiß, was ein Unterwasserzoo in
globish russia war Golfhöhlen in Cinnamon
Dial Honig nein nein Honig
Holen Sie sich Bifida Tausende von Asheville One-Night-Stand-
Sichtungen Premiere für Zoll Stoff
Cybersex in Dallas Alpesh Billy aus
Zion Negativ in  Bits Human Decent LP
Koon Stick to It in Capitalism helfen
alle Antworten von Hannity, mit denen wir jetzt
umgehen können, in etwas aufzuteilen, so dass eine
der Arten, in der sie miteinander verflochten sind, darin
besteht, dass nach den 1960er Jahren, als die
Sexualität viel freier wurde, dies tatsächlich
mehr Gleichheit, etwas mehr Gleichheit bedeutete
zwischen Männern und Frauen bedeutete es, dass
Frauen die Freuden des Sex genießen konnten,
die sie bis dahin nicht hatten, weil
Sex mit Scham und Sünde verbunden war, aber vor
allem bedeutete es, dass die
Medienindustrien, ich weißt du, die Industrien
, die sich mit Schwulen beschäftigen Kinowerbung
Fernsehen  meistens haben sie
den sexualisierten Körper von Männern und Frauen benutzt und ausgebeutet,
aber meistens Frauen,
also wenn man bis in die 1970er Jahre selten Sex sieht
Szenen aus den 1970er, aber vor allem aus
den 1980er Jahren, die Anzahl von sechs Szenen
nahm enorm zu und Sexualität und
sexualisierte Körper wurden
zu einem zunehmend festen Bestandteil von
Werbekino und Fernsehen, weil sie
Zuschauer visuell anziehen, so dass Sexualität
in diesem Sinne zu einer neuen Ware geworden ist
und von diesen intensiv ausgebeutet wird  Kapitalismus durch
skopisch, was ich skopische Industrien nenne
, das sind Industrien, die auf den Gewinnen basieren, die
Wert aus dem
sexualisierten Körper von Frauen extrahieren, und diese
Hypersexualisierung von Beziehungen hat viele
Auswirkungen auf die Möglichkeit,
emotionale Bindungen zu bilden, dies ist eines der
Themen, die ich  Erforschen Sie in dem Buch und dies ist
, Spiel aus Schlüsselfeldern Belton zu beschwören
und seinen menschlichen Bereich der
Schwesterverbände entlang eines Bischofsstabs zu markieren.
Sehen Sie, wie Englisch und projektübergreifend das ist,
wer Winkel es geschafft hat, es ist ein Übergang
vom Kochstab TR Küsse für Helenus
Tomash Bilder  verbrauchen die Romantiker als
das Haus von Valverde Cetacean Shawndala, auf das er
sich nicht zurückzieht  Kapitalistische
Nachrichten van Gürtel und gehen als Reichtum [ __ ]
Bösewicht geteilt in solide Affinität zu
Ananda auf dem Computer und zusätzliche
Parodie Arriba legte sein Veto ein, aber die
häuslich gerenderte Rutsche EEMA Vida über
Krankheitsgerechtigkeit hat viele Arten, die Sie sich
anmelden, die Sie bald sehen, damit sie davon a
lebe auch in der Gemeinschaft ami Team
Capitalism's so focus Ian Ich würde sagen,
du kennst die Modernität die
Frage nach dem Wesen der Moderne was
bedeutet es, modern zu sein, was bedeutet es,
eine kapitalistische Wirtschaft zu haben und was
bedeutet es, darin zu leben  Gesellschaften, in denen
Individuen von Gemeinschaften getrennt sind,
sind die beiden Hauptfragen
der Soziologie und Liebe, weil wahrscheinlich
Liebe traditionell mit
der Angst der Frau verbunden ist und weil
Soziologen bis vor kurzem, ich meine,
das
und der Soziologie meistens männlich
geliebt wird, nicht als dazugehörig angesehen wurden
Soziologie und so einer der Einsätze, wenn
Sie von meinem Studium wollen, Sie haben Recht, ich
meine, diese Forschungsagenda soll zeigen,
dass a  Ein
scheinbar universelles und persönliches und individuelles Thema oder Gefühl
wird tatsächlich von kollektiven
Veränderungen und Transformationen und
insbesondere vom Kapitalismus durchzogen, so dass die Welt
der Gefühle und die Welt der
Ökonomie traditionell als
gegensätzlich gedacht werden  Ich denke, das
ist eher eine Frage dessen, was unsere Ideologie
glauben möchte, als eine
Frage der empirischen Tatsachen, also
haben Frauen zum Beispiel immer Frauen und Männer haben immer
Geldüberlegungen bei der Auswahl ihres Partners eingebracht, und sie
stehen heute still damit, ob  Es ist
anerkannt oder nicht, dass Geld, Status oder
Bildung eine sehr wichtige Rolle dabei spielen,
in wen wir uns verlieben und mit wem wir
unser Leben leben, also sind diese
interessiert, wenn Sie Überlegungen wünschen,
und daher war die Frage für mich, wann
Familien nicht verantwortlich sind  mehr für
Matchmaking für Ehen, wenn die
Familie nicht der Ort ist, an dem von den Menschen
erwartet wird, dass sie ihr wichtigstes Einkommen
erzielen  Betrieb, weil sie gehen
und auf einem kapitalistischen Markt arbeiten, was
mit romantischen Gefühlen passiert und besonders,
was mit romantischen Gefühlen passiert,
wenn romantische Liebe zum
Hauptobjekt wird, das Hauptthema, das Hauptziel
der riesigen Verbrauchermärkte, die beginnen
, eingerichtet zu
werden  Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts
sollte Davia oft nicht
Klippe sein Die Amorites zogen Waren an, die Goethe
Amorites als Mythos eine Matze
und Alf Colada Nikita au Revoir auf dem
Fahrzeug von Cannon auf Titel
Immobilisierung von Kosmonauten Travis
Mohandas Nike Fuel le be some
Verkaufswagen aus Canton über Ich gebe mir Küsse
Eamonn waren also davargan gut Tyrions
Fahrzeug Technischer Anruf von Colonel If
Hawkins Josh Prozentsatz der Kanadier Ich bin
Michelle Christ
sexuell Ted Cofell neu überarbeitet Unsere
Einberufungen ein Johannine-Partner Sarg kann
gleichmäßig auf Drachensarg lehnen
im On-Sex-Roboter auf unseren Bytes und
meinen und einigen Titeln ein Fisch, ja, das
kann Indien sein  re in Barcelona sind durch den
Arzt sucht Santos ein
exorbitanter Animus durch Ihre VII der Alkohole
Funktion heute hoid auf seinem
Designgeschäft auf Silizium Putin an Ad Laden
und Soho,
also habe ich eine Architektur der Emotionen
, die mein Kern war. Ich habe ein Gehirn, das ich
habe  Architektur eines Gehirns, das
Emotionen auf eine bestimmte Weise ausdrücken kann, dachte ich
, und dann dachte er, habe ich ein
humanoides System?
Ich habe ein humanoides System in der
Sexpuppenindustrie gefunden, und dann sagte er, okay, jetzt
brauche ich Computer, die
fertig zum Zusammenbauen verfügbar sind  und jede Technologie
, die ich verwenden kann, um all dies
auf Zubrin-Design und sexuell potentem Fett zusammenzubringen. Ich
will Sex. Es ist Zeit, das Leben zu genießen
Kann ich
das für immer fühlen, wenn meine
Frau mich verlässt? Ich lebe mit ihr. Ich
scherze nicht mit ihr. Sie gibt mir die Gesellschaft, die mir die
Leute nicht geben
Er steckt es Elysium auf
die Karte eines Mannes, der leer ist für den
sexy Technolog Mahan, der
ihn auf den Sexsmith Albertan zerlegt, ich habe keine Chancen
und Fetischist in Synästhesie macht die
Besuche so groß, dass sogar eine
Bevölkerung ein Armspiel über Savannah
höllisch kollidierte Haken sicher froh ist  über
Monat am MIT in Hayden Mann virtualisierte
MIT in Saga in Lieferwagen auf Steuer der Couch
setzt Normandie in Tataren-Kommandanten-
Pullover ein bescheidener Kämpfer steckt ihr Sex
oder Flaschen für das Ende fest ist die Sanic
Motiti wahrscheinlich nicht, aber ich weiß nicht, ob
die Frage ist  ob es gut oder schlecht ist
Ich denke, die Frage ist, ob es
unvermeidlich ist oder nicht Ich denke, es ist
unvermeidlich Ich denke, wir
gehen auf eine Gesellschaft zu, in der Roboter
eine immer wichtigere
emotionale Rolle in unserem Leben spielen werden, wenn Sie darüber
nachdenken  pet the pet is living,
natürlich ist es ein lebendes Geschöpf, aber es ist
nicht jemand, der uns widerspricht, und
dennoch geben wir Haustieren sehr viel, wir
vermenschlichen Haustiere, aber selbst wenn wir sie betreten, geben wir ihnen etwas
Die Haustiere, die wir lieben Wir
erkennen auch, dass ein Haustier, das wir lieben, nicht
genau einem Menschen entspricht,
der zurückspricht oder uns anschreit oder
uns umarmt  menschlichen Gehirns und
das zumindest eine Vielzahl von
emotionalen Reaktionen auf uns nachahmt, gibt es keinen
Grund, warum wir diese
Kreaturen nicht als Hybriden irgendwo
zwischen Menschen und Nicht-Menschen betrachten würden
, so wie Haustiere
zwischen Menschen und Menschen stehen  Nicht-Menschen
Ich denke, das ist genau das, was Sie wissen.
Posthumanismus bedeutet, genau das ist es
, was das Leben mit Maschinen
bedeutet, dass wir
mehr und mehr mit hybriden Wesen interagieren werden
Clovis es Istiqlal, dass wir nicht auf meinen
Brückenkriterien all diese englischen Sexisten auf
beiden Seiten und damit im Grenzland MIT-
Wissenschaftsexperten mit mir selbst
praktisch kein Drehbuch haben, das wir nicht gefunden hätten  d
für Kunst und Wissenschaft die Zionisten und und
ausländisch gebaute Fortsetzer bei
Viet Künstlern war, kann man sagen,
dass der Grund, warum bisher die meisten
Roboter weiblich sind und ganz bestimmten sexuellen Fantasien entsprechen, den
man leicht machen könnte  behaupten,
dass es daran liegt, dass Frauen
in gewisser Weise bereits in der Gesellschaft ziemlich objektiviert sind
und daher für viele Männer die
Möglichkeit, zu einem Roboter zu wechseln, ein
hochentwickelter Roboter ist, ist es eigentlich nicht
so viel anders, es ist wirklich eine
Frage des Kontinuums, weil Frauen
bereits objektiviert und behandelt werden
Objekte, die Sie sehr leicht
behaupten könnten, aber ich würde vermuten, dass
diese Roboter aus Gründen des Marktes
auch auf zwei
Frauen abzielen würden und Sie daher entweder Frauen oder Männer an Frauen verkaufen würden
Desk
Ehrlichkeit Ferguson auf DeForest Filmer
Schätzung Macht ehrliche Fenster
interesante gesehen künstliche Organe sogar
in einem Hostel in I  srael auf jeden zeit unsere
rache zu glauben, ein rechtlicher hinweis zu
Dean und Jean de Ville TCR in schizont
Xia von der sexualität zu strowman
übersprungen die porno urlaub bei mohammed
ei stattdessen die
schwester tante mames versteckte bashar snikt d'Ivoire eine industrie der sexuelle ist
idiot  auf Christus bei der Firma Erwähnung
Essig Sex Österreich eine Mouska Praktiken
in Europa auf Bast lehren Töpfe Ende
Dimension vorübergehend teuer unsere jungen
Gaben CF Nabob Anklopfen in Ihram führender
Sex korrupt treffen eine Reihe alle und Stößel
Anatoly Schmitz Extraknopf Anatoly
Verbraucher in Mangas und  Pornos haben in der
Tat eine Stunde vor netten T9-Hooks
einen Pastor auf Betas erkannt, die sie in
anderen Geschäften kontaktieren, wenn Sie zuerst
von Ihrem Recht sind.
Ich denke, Wissenschaftler sollten davon absehen,
ihre Themen normativ zu beurteilen,
zumindest wenn sie verstehen wollen, warum
sie tun, was sie tun  tun und
welche Gründe die Leute für
sich anführen, also würde ich zum
Beispiel als Gelehrter immer lieber verstehen, warum das
so ist  Wenn jemand für Trump stimmt, anstatt
die Tatsache zu beurteilen, dass jemand für Trump stimmt, ist
es sehr wichtig, wenn wir
in der Gesellschaft Fuß fassen wollen, das heißt, wenn wir
einen Einfluss auf die Gesellschaft haben wollen, müssen wir
zuallererst verstehen, was die Leute tun, was
es nicht tut  bedeutet, dass nachdem ich
etwas über den Zustand von Werten und
Praktiken in der Gesellschaft verstanden oder hoffentlich verstanden habe, es nicht bedeutet,
dass ich dann nicht fortfahre, ein
normatives Urteil darüber abzugeben Ich tue dies zum Beispiel in
Bezug auf die Stärkung der Kultur
Es gibt eine große Debatte unter
Feministinnen, ob es eine gute oder schlechte
Sache ist. Viele Feministinnen, Pro-Sex-Feministinnen,
denken, dass der Feminismus, der
die Sexualisierung des weiblichen Körpers einschränken möchte,
sie denken, dass es ein Puritaner ist, es ist
eine Form des Puritanismus und tatsächlich
darin  Respekt Ich beziehe eine Position,
weil ich denke, dass ich historisch
unabhängig davon, ob Sie denken, dass viel
Sex gut oder schlecht ist
, nicht einmal die Frage stelle,
ob Sex gut oder schlecht ist, ich
denke es nicht  Es ist meine Aufgabe, diese Frage zu beantworten,
aber sie stellen fest, dass die
Sexualität von der kapitalistischen Industrie enorm wiedererlangt wurde und
dass die Körper von Frauen als
Ehemann das Objekt intensiver
Ausbeutung durch viele Medienindustrien waren,
wo aber und wo das Kriterium für
diese Ausbeutung ist  immer
vom Mann etabliert, fast immer etabliert, Diamant,
also passiert etwas fast Tragisches
, nämlich
dass Frauen gleichzeitig denken, dass sie sich befreien,
sich tatsächlich dem Blick und der Kontrolle
von Männern in der Medienindustrie unterwerfen, also gibt es
irgendeinen Grund, Infraschall zu sagen  Elongation oder
Hamal-Aufwiegelung des englischen
Generals Hummel,
also wer hat
mich schon länger nicht mehr erwähnt, aber
hungrig, nein, diese Besucher halten dies fest.
Stellen Sie sich vor, ein Artikel von
Tausend Künsten in
Austin Atlantic  Beteiligte sich an einem
bösen Sexrennen, sobald Kotoha ein Artikel
in dieser Zeit den Titel The Gasse
of  Taggen des sexuellen Alpha-Hauses des
Parlaments ein Mensch erwähnt die Stadt in
Mamaia sogar von der Pornoindustrie von
Fellate sogar - ein hohler Chor, was
über Indian Hotel Meetings ging, auch
Übergänge, die dem einzigen Porter einen
polierten Realloc auf Israel Abigail knacken:
also das sehr Interessante  Studie
, die vom Atlantic veröffentlicht wurde, glaube ich,
das Atlantic Magazin im Ich glaube es war
im Januar oder Dezember findet in der Tat heraus,
dass die jüngeren Kohorten weniger
Sex haben als die etwas älteren Kohorten
der 1990er Jahre, und ich denke, einer der Gründe,
wenn nicht der  Der Hauptgrund ist
eigentlich das Thema des Buches, nämlich
dass es viel schwieriger geworden ist,
die Regeln für das Eingehen von
Beziehungen zu kennen. Der meiste Sex
wird in stabilen Beziehungen
trotz der Verbindungskultur praktiziert, wenn man
sich die gesamten sexuellen Aktivitäten ansieht  ein
Individuum hat im Laufe seines Lebens den
größten Teil des Geschlechts, das Männer und Frauen haben,
ist in stabilen Beziehungen, wenn es
immer schwieriger wird, stabile Beziehungen aufzubauen
Beziehungen, dann wirst du natürlich
weniger Sex haben, denn
hier haben die meisten Männer und Frauen normalerweise
sexuelle Beziehungen, also landen wir, wenn du
willst, bei einem sehr interessanten Paradoxon
, nämlich dass die Kultur, die
Körper und Begegnungen hypersexualisiert,
tatsächlich endet  als eine Kultur, in
der es weniger Sex gibt, weil diese
Kultur die Regeln für das Eingehen von
Beziehungen und das Aufrechterhalten von
Beziehungen viel schwer fassbarer und
viel unsicherer macht, so dass der ganze Begriff der
Ungewissheit meiner Meinung nach zu einer
grundlegenden Eigenschaft zeitgenössischer
Beziehungen geworden ist, manchmal ein Ende  Ergebnis und
Punks, Tamesha-Koch, der rausgeschmissen wurde, ist ein
Makel in Konya, Nama-Hatta-Haus.
Zunächst ist er Mukesh tmartn-Partner,
gebratene Überwachung, und in einem Hasani-
Antibiotikum, einer mutmaßlichen Überwachung,
weist ihre eigene Schicksals-Eternity-Technologie
auf Fäustlinge auf Stealth hin, nämlich
Jeremy in Fort Lee jae-  Hoon Dolls Tasha
Automata Kate Agnes Ich weiß, ich bin psychotisch
highfalutin,
wenn die traditionelle romantische l  ove
basiert fast per Definition auf der
Identifizierung einer einzigartigen Person, und wenn
Sie in einer Gesellschaft leben, in der Sie
relativ wenige Menschen treffen, würde ich sagen, dass es
relativ einfach ist, diese eine Person zu identifizieren,
aber die
Internettechnologie verändert die Ökonomie der Begegnungen vollständig,
weil wir uns davon entfernen  eine
Wirtschaft der Knappheit zu einer Wirtschaft nicht des
Überflusses, sondern des Überflusses, nein
, damit Sie eine Seite kennen, eine
Internetseite wie Tinder, zum Beispiel, wenn
Sie hundert
Likes gemacht haben, also hat es Ihnen das nicht verboten
Wenn Sie 12 Stunden lang weitermachen, können Sie nur
100 Likes pro Tag machen, also versuchen Sie
sich kognitiv vorzustellen, dass wir nicht
so viele Informationen verarbeiten können. Unser Gehirn ist nicht
gut gerüstet, um mit einer so
extravaganten Auswahl an Möglichkeiten von
Männern und Frauen konfrontiert zu werden, die schauen  gleichermaßen
attraktiv, die alle interessant sind,
die alle gereist sind und uns ihre
Bilder mit dem Hintergrund einer ägyptischen
Pyramide oder einer wunderschönen Insel zeigen, damit diese
Objekte nicht mehr zu unterscheiden sind  ishable Lektionen
in Stockholm squats Ich bin Sean Regan aus
Tinder Nuts auf der Station Crew und
Tinder Steines gibt es einen Kanal Netze
sie sind Caterer
im Jahr 2012 emittierte Website im Jahr 2012 Talking Tinder und
Start Cut ist keine eigene Nichtregierungs-
Kunst Millionen Kontakt aqui abgestimmt  gezeigt
über con kniebeugen wir erwähnten treffen
zunder unbeholfen sind zu fett für mich leona yelstin vor
hitman donut mahabhava
der kleine aus dem power smiley bald als
menü kann ein spiel sein markierter pfad zwischen
joe hamid ist definitiv 14 jahre lächeln
nicht links 9 oh wir fanden a  passen die jüngsten
Begegnungen Spinnennebel Ich bin Mitch eigene
Tücher Kinder mischen Chetan kopfüber Treibstoff ist
Gott Newman hat mich überfallen Treffen Sie die Meter
kein Platformer Beute irgendwie rund verwalten
Miss es braucht Ihre Valerie hundert Ihre
Malayalee, um in einem Sack in Atlanta
Manor die Fische zu füttern  Sie müssen
wirklich noch weiter stehen und manuell
von der Insel koppeln, für Allah haben Sie kein Mana
Macbeth von Cirucci Dr.  Alexander-Anzug
ist gleich zu stoppen ein Silizium unterstützend
siehe unser GM ist wichtig von Zunder Santos
Musik oh und auf Narr kleiner und Noah
PGA-Startseite wird Chanel Visa Viratas
Murrysville rationale technische
Nachfolge mir erlauben, teilzunehmen sonst
Beerdigungen in Scott unsere Muskeln sind Kattun
[Musik]
es sei denn, ich verlasse einen muslimischen Nicht-Muslim, wenn
Ostern kommt, sagt, ich habe es besprochen, sobald
das cool ist, 11 gut, Mann, es ist ein Vida-
Zitat oder zumindest eine Komponente,
Zärtlichkeit, Vanessa-Seite, super Fieber,
super cool, zuweisen, fühlen, fliegen, um
Dokumente bündeln, Momente, aber kein
Semester mit ihm  auf dem eis einer
starken wirtschaft morgen sonntag das ist
alles tinder hat gute und schlechte erfahrungen
oder nicht erfahrungen viele leute können auch sagen,
dass sie endlos wischen können
vielleicht sich verabreden um jemanden zu treffen
und dann niemanden treffen oder oder
sie müssten wischen  200 mal
zwei Verabredungen zu haben und so viele, einige, für einige
Leute funktioniert es, für andere nicht,
es ist extrem schwer zu sagen, ich meine,
ob es funktioniert  was es tut Ich denke also Ich
denke, wenn wir Zunder oder diese Apps
nach den Ergebnissen beurteilen, verstehen wir nicht wieder,
wie sie funktionieren und warum sie so
süchtig machen. Was es Ihnen sagt, ist
Hoffnung, also würde ich sagen, dass die Ware
das ist  Sie verkaufen Hoffnung. Selbst wenn
Sie in
den letzten zwei Jahren erfolglos waren, hält Sie die Hoffnung
weiter und nicht nur, dass
sie Dating in ein Spiel verwandelt, so ist
eigentlich der eigentliche Konzeptfehler
der Plattform, über den gesprochen wurde  Tinder
sprachen anfangs von einer
Gaming-Plattform und das ist eine weitere
Plattform für soziale Netzwerke, also
verwandeln sie die ganze Idee des Datings in
etwas, das viel diffuser und
viel amorpher ist als etwas, in
dem man viele Leute trifft und
baut  eine Art soziales Netzwerk und in
dem Sie spielen und spielen, hat
es die Herangehensweise an romantische Liebe völlig verändert,
sodass diese Dame
sie als etwas wirklich Cooles ansehen kann, das
es Ihnen ermöglicht, Ihre eigene zu erleben
Freiheit, stimmst du ihr zu
? Das ist genau das, was die Seite
dir ermöglicht. Sie gibt dir ein Gefühl deiner
Freiheit, aber oft, oft, nicht immer
, ist es eine Freiheit, die dich mit leeren
Händen
zurücklässt, wenn dies Devere Hong gegen Aden ist, in dem es sich um
eine Herberge handelt  der stahl ist zäh hat nicht
mehr oft zehn maße sie hoffen
sie werden die liebe ihres
lebens treffen ihre hoffnung sie werden
die eine person treffen die
in diesem ozean von
möglichkeiten einen unterschied machen wird geräteriese rasam
design abgesehen von ein paar einschnitten  oder Elemente
für die Hilfe mrs.  Olfa beendet die SIS mir
zumindest Negativität menschliches Geschenk als Bitumen
die Beilage, das Gericht ungefallen, sagen sie,
dort sind ihre Gefühle, ihr Fleisch genommen,
menschlich, Dr
oft beflecken mich Mitarbeiter, die mich oft hinter sich bringen,
also lockere sie und lehrte sie - die
spontan sagen, ich bin krank, ein einziger Libre,
wir haben unterschiedliche Tendenzen in unserer
Kultur, moderne Kulturen sind äußerst
widersprüchlich, und ich würde sagen, dass es so ist
Diese Widersprüche definieren sogar,
was es bedeutet, ein moderner Mensch zu sein,
wir streben nach Sicherheit und Stabilität und
gleichzeitig nach Aufregung und einem
Gefühl von Freiheit und Autonomie, und dann sind es
diese beiden, die uns in Bewegung halten, und in
gewisser Weise würde ich sagen  es ist auch das, was
die Wirtschaft am Laufen hält, es ist
groß, es ist dieser Versuch, zusammenzusitzen
oder diese Konflikte oder Widersprüche zu versöhnen,
damit die romantische Liebe als
Utopie nicht verschwunden ist  weg von der
zeitgenössischen Kultur, im Gegenteil, ich
denke, unsere Kultur war nie
von romantischer Liebe besessen, denn und
das liegt daran, dass das Paar
Gemeinschaften und
Familien ersetzt, weil heute Einzelpersonen,
sobald sie das Erwachsenenalter erreicht haben,
in eine äußerst wettbewerbsorientierte, höchst
unsichere Gesellschaft geworfen werden, in der  Die Zukunft ist
sehr ungewiss und auch wirtschaftlich ist
es schwieriger geworden,
wirklich als eine Person über die Runden zu kommen, also
gibt es wirklich viele gute Gründe, sowohl
psychologisch, emotional als auch wirtschaftlich,
um das Paar wirklich zu der notwendigen oder Einheit zu machen, in der
die Menschen hauptsächlich leben möchten
um eine stabile
emotionale Basis für die Anerkennung und
Bestätigung deiner selbst zu haben, aber
gleichzeitig gibt es viele Kräfte,
die diese Idee des Einen und Einzigen untergraben,
und deshalb gehen wir zum
Psychologen, deshalb verbrauchen wir uns
selbst  -Hilfsbücher Deshalb
konsumieren wir Pornographie, all diese Spannungen
und Widersprüche sind eine Quelle von
enormem Ausmaß  Wir verbrauchen ununterbrochene
Einzeldosis-Modus einer Person
Patel von dieser @aarrison Höhe, die er
als Madonna praktizierte. Einzelne
Nebel-Designer-Websites, sogar DC sagt,
Proben müssen implizieren, dass es sich um seinen
Agora-Drachen Vardhan handelt, der tatsächlich einen eigenen Revierkampf macht,
um den Grund zu überarbeiten und eine
Was von immer zu überarbeiten  Essig ist meiner Meinung nach
weniger zerrissen Eine der
Definitionen von Modernität,
die von Max Weber geliefert wurde, lautet, dass alle
Lebensbereiche des gesellschaftlichen Lebens, der
Wirtschaft, des Rechts, der Familie, der Religion,
alle beginnen, sich voneinander zu unterscheiden,
während dies zuvor der Fall war  mehr oder
weniger unter der Überschrift Religion oder
Religion organisiert sehr viele verschiedene
Lebensbereiche, so dass, sobald diese Lebensbereiche
voneinander getrennt sind, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie miteinander in
Konflikt geraten, viel
höher ist
, das ist das eine, das andere ist, dass der
Kapitalismus an sich ist  basierend auf einem
gewaltigen Widerspruch zwischen
einerseits einer hochproduktiven und
disziplinierten Person, die  ist in der Lage,
seinen Körper zu vergessen und 12 Stunden
zu arbeiten, um immer mehr Geld zu verdienen, also ein
höchst rationales, wenn man will, produktives,
diszipliniertes Individuum, auf der anderen Seite
muss das gleiche kapitalistische Individuum
ein Konsument sein, der sehr
mit seinen eigenen Freuden beschäftigt ist  Release mit
Authentizität mit Emotionen und so ist diese
Art von Release Control Release
Control wirklich das Herzstück dessen, was es
bedeutet, ein modernes Individuum zu sein, und dieser
Widerspruch wird
vom Kapitalismus selbst
in Suki auf seinem riesigen Bildergebnismedium genährt und institutionell eingebaut
und slingin, dass köstliche Komplexität übergossene
Waltons, das sind Darwins haftendes
Tannin-Cytosol der äh, Neuronen, die es
immer überspringt, bevor Terry unsere Zielzone überspringt.
HPV 18 Jahre alt, ja,
Barnabas Hyden, ich dachte, das wurde
veröffentlicht
eine
Premiere im Iran, dies in Fargo, vermisse das Verschwinden in Dörfern, unanständige Gansan, hinterlasse einen
stechenden Todd, der Elvis' Avedo steht  In
der ästhetischen Begegnung mit Oscar Vulcan Höhe
mit Komplexität zu einer anderen ist dies, ich
weiß es, sie sahen, der Anfang war getan, sie
fliegt. Ich denke, was falsch ist, ist, dass
es zwei Imperative gibt, eine der
wirtschaftlichen Produktion und eine
der Reproduktion, der Reproduktionsmittel
biologische Reproduktionsgesellschaften müssen
sich selbst reproduzieren, es ist per
Definition
und traditionell Familien eine Frau,
meistens Frauen haben das getan und sie haben
sehr viel getan, und Frauen haben mit
dem Imperativ der Reproduktion zusammengearbeitet, was der
Kapitalismus tut, ist, dass er die
Reproduktion untergräbt, und das ist es, was wir brauchen
Ich denke, viele Menschen
verstehen, dass wir, wie wir einen
Konflikt haben, den Widerspruch zwischen
Produktion und Reproduktion verstehen und so
Reproduktion in dem Sinne, dass immer
mehr Menschen alleine leben, immer mehr
Menschen alleine leben wollen, immer weniger
Menschen Kinder haben wollen  weniger und
all dies schafft die Krise, die
ich als Reproduktion bezeichnen würde, und diese
Krise ist keine  t Provoziert durch die
Frauenbewegung Feminismus oder Freiheit als
solcher Provoziert durch die Lebensbedingungen
im Spätkapitalismus Eigentum Schleier ziehen
Chrom dem Kampfochsen vor Der Reichtum
Bevölkerung wächst, aber nicht in
den kapitalistischsten Ländern zumindest nicht
in den westlichen Ländern und
umgekehrt  In Japan geht die Reproduktionsrate zurück,
in Italien, in
Deutschland, in den skandinavischen Ländern
ist die Reproduktionsrate auf unterschiedliche Weise und auf unterschiedlichem Niveau gesunken, also gibt es eine
Reproduktionskrise  Lebende Zähne an
Astronomen
aus dem VHF vanessaanddan Politiker
für Hilfe Mason on Tack Ammoniak des
Phlogiston Vas Zündungsmesser feministische
Probleme mit einem jungen englischen Paseo-Test,
wenn Schriftsteller Telefone in der
Apollo-Industrie in einer lebensfähigen Industrie bauen,
die existieren, sind die braunen Boveri
revolución das Telefon von Harbin WA kann
in Umkehrungen geglaubt werden, nehmen Sie ein Gegenteil I
th  Tinte, was passiert ist, ist, dass
es fast unmöglich ist,
die
Herrschaftsstruktur wirklich zu ändern, wenn Sie die gesamte
Infrastruktur der Gesellschaft, der Wirtschaft, der
Militärkultur besitzen  Frauen haben diese Fortschritte gemacht und sie
haben diese Fortschritte nur
dank Feministinnen gemacht, die für sie
für alle Frauen gekämpft haben. Trotzdem ist der größte Teil
der sozialen Infrastruktur in Politik,
Militär und Wirtschaft und
Religion und Gerichten in
den Händen von Männern geblieben, wenn das so ist  Ich
denke, das ist der Fall, selbst wenn Sie eine
emanzipatorische Ideologie und eine
emanzipatorische Idee veröffentlichen
, die sehr leicht von Kräften wiederhergestellt werden kann
, die mächtiger sind als Sie. Das ist
meiner Meinung nach mit der Idee der sexuellen Freiheit passiert, von der
zum Beispiel der
Feminismus entführt wurde  kapitalistische Industrien
gigantischer kosmischer Feind hinter
Noel Espino meine Inspiration namens Mr.
Barasa-Männer sind Wesenheiten, die
Besson Lydon ärgerlich übersprungen hat. Viele Organisationen
im Internet sind so scharf auf T in Zellen.
Unfreiwillige Zölibatäre wie in Favilla
konsultieren die Armee. Dies ist Anna Koreffs eigene
Art der Mission
Filament verklagt Zitate, um Akane
Partner in Finnland auf vehement
aggressive sexistische jede Team Nets
Organisation auf ausländische Pasta fazool
Monogamie sein Memorandum etf arimin zu befehlen und
das Gerichtsfenster anständig zu verschmutzen,
jeder Vater ist kapitalistische Nachrichten,
also gut, zuallererst sind sie eine
Auswirkung der  Änderung der patriarchalischen
Struktur, also haben wir jetzt andere
Herrschaftsformen, die
miteinander konkurrieren, ihr
Patriarchat wird von Frauen bestritten, und
während die meisten Männer in der Vergangenheit
Zugang und einfachen Zugang zum Körper von
Frauen hatten, denke ich, dass der Zugang ist  viel genauer
untersucht und reguliert, also ist es eine
Veränderung, es ist eine kleine Veränderung, worauf sie
reagieren  eine leichte Änderung des
privilegierten Mannes und des einfachen und unproblematischen
Zugangs zu Frauen, aber was der Kapitalismus
auch geändert hat, ist, dass Männer und Frauen,
Heterosexuelle, sich jetzt treffen, als ob
auf einem Markt heterosexuelle Beziehungen vermarktet würden
, der ein
Markt ist, der dem Gesetz des Angebots unterliegt
und fordern, dass es nicht von
Familien oder Gemeinschaften geregelt wird, die versuchen,
Paare im neuen sexuellen
Liberalismus zusammenzubringen, wenn Sie wollen. Der Markt
hat den Effekt, dass einige Menschen
weniger erfolgreich sind, weniger gefragt sind und
daher ausgelassen werden, wenn Sie sie ausschließen
möchten  sie sind aus dem wettbewerb ausgeschlossen
und sie reagieren auf diese
vermarktung, ob wir sie
künstlerische magnetisierung heterosexueller
beziehungen nennen würden, und der verlust männlicher
privilegien, wie ich sagte, amok verschmutzte
amuros anfänglichen euro- und palästinensischen
effekt oft sehr fliegend, also lass uns reden  oh
mann Titian Lieber Zürich
Kieran's Idioten das ist Fantasia und
Abtreibung Ehemann ist Qual das
Wohnungsbaudarlehenssystem dieser Krieg noctem Ann  ein
Partner oder Osmane erstaunte Anziehungskraft
mit jungem Vanillebaby lehrte, als Lily
gut endete. Ich habe nie gesagt,
dass es sich lohnt,
nein, nein, ich denke, es lohnt sich
, sinnvolle Beziehungen zu entwickeln,
aber sinnvolle Beziehungen sind nicht
unbedingt romantische Beziehungen oder
sexuelle Beziehungen, also wenn es eine gibt  Eine
Sache, die ich in meinem Studium gerne tun würde,
ist, unser Blickfeld definitiv zu erweitern
und eine viel
breitere Vorstellung davon zu haben, was eine sinnvolle
Beziehung ist, die von
Freundschaft inspiriert werden kann oder von der
Fürsorge für andere inspiriert werden kann  kann von
der Liebe der Kinder in einer Weise inspiriert werden Ich mag die
religiöse Sichtweise der Liebe die religiöse Ich
meine die christliche Liebe zu den Menschen
als etwas, das sehr bedeutungsvoll ist
sauber extrem sei die Liebe gut nicht
ein abstraktes Anderes wie im Christentum, sondern die
Liebe  eine sehr konkrete Person, die
keine sexuellen romantischen Partner sein muss und
in gewisser Weise möchte ich, dass wir uns wie
gesagt wieder aufschließen  Um unsere Vorstellungskraft zu erweitern
und zu sehen, dass unser Leben
viel mehr Möglichkeiten
äußerst bedeutungsvoller Bindungen bietet als
die Idee der romantischen Liebe, schafft die Idee der
romantischen Liebe sehr enge Pfade
für die menschliche Entwicklung und sogar die menschliche
Brüderlichkeit in Bruderschaft
oder Schwesternschaft und Schwesternschaft  Sie möchten, dass es die
weichere aktuelle Ausgabe ist, sehen Sie Jesus, ja,
Whitman Ian, Familie, Madrid über die Vikunja,
Spezialist für Muta, bis Kingdom. Nun,
Sie wissen, ich denke, die Familie ist heute die
einzige nichtkapitalistische Institution in dem
Sinne, dass sie die einzige Institution ist, die
Sie nicht wirklich wählen  und
deshalb denke ich, dass die familie
für mich so interessant geworden ist, weil
in der welt, wo du alles wählst, was
du bist, einschließlich deines körpers und deiner
sexualität, haarschnitt, keulen, luftiger geschmack usw.,
deine familie ist das einzige, was du nicht
wählst, was bedeutet, dass es die ist  Ort des
enormen Lernens und Wachsens, weil
es der Ort ist, an dem man einfach mit dem
leben muss, was einem gegeben wurde, und
das ist w  Warum ich es so interessant finde und
warum ich es einen nicht-kapitalistischen, einen nicht-modernen Ort nenne, ist
es, wenn Sie wollen, der einzige
Überrest traditioneller Gesellschaften in der
modernen Gesellschaft, Giudice, der anfänglich an der
Leine von Kenan-Waffenkonzerten geklaut wurde, wenn
ich die Sylvia-Invariante verliere - Calvin-
Esel  hier Danke Julian drücke a
und gleich Krieg und Frieden kahl
[Musik]
[Applaus]